foreign
[Music]
hello I'm Jason alter I'm head of
scientific Affairs for exosome
Diagnostics which is part of the larger
biotechnic Corporation
exosome is based in Waltham
Massachusetts
and we specialize in being leaders in
exosome research and the utility of
exosomes for clinical applications my
specific background is in prostate
cancer I've helped and contributed and
participated in the development of a
number of assays over the last 20 years
all focused in helping clinicians make
better or more informed decisions in the
area of prostate cancer what I'd like to
talk to you about today is truly
exciting Technology based on exosomes
that are not widely known I'd like to
tell you something about exosomes and
then I'd like to tell you about how
they're being used clinically in an
actual assay
so there are three goals from this
presentation the first is to explain
what exosomes are
for those of you are not aware this is a
fairly new field of exciting discovery
to talk to you about what the clinical
challenges that we're applying them to
and then to show you how exosomes are
providing benefits to patients and their
physicians in the area of prostate
cancer early detection
so let's first talk about exosomes and
what are they
well the first thing to understand is
that exosomes are very very small
they're actually measured in nanometers
and nanometers means dwarf in Greek and
they're actually on the order of
billionths of a meter
so exosomes are truly very small micro
vesicles that are Shed from pretty much
every cell that we know about
they're on the order of viruses
and this particular image is giving you
an idea of scale of a typical cell which
is measured in microns anywhere from 8
to 12 microns for an a typical cell from
there you go to platelets then bacteria
and then you go to the level of viruses
and exosomes are so small that they're
on the order of viruses and we talk
about them in the range of 30 to 100
nanometers typically
now like most great things in science
exosomes were originally thought to be
junk
so in 1967 there was some of the
original notation of micro vesicles and
at the time as research progressed and
we're talking on the order of a small
number of papers per year
exosomes were thought to be junk and it
reminds me back to when we first learned
about introns and DNA and they were
originally thought to be junk TNA with
no real value
and over time as you look at this
timeline exosomes were determined to be
secreted from various cell types and
involved in various activities ranging
from managing presentation to ultimately
where we now know that they're mostly
involved is cell to cell communication
and this paper that came out in 2008 was
actually quite pivotal but pivotal in
the area of exosome research by skagadel
because it determined and was able to
demonstrate that exosomes not only have
RNA but can use that RNA to modify the
recipient cells Dr skog on this paper
was the founder of exosome and is one of
the world leaders and exosome as a as an
entity as a corporation is actually
doing a lot of The Cutting Edge research
which is typically unusual because in
typical science the academics lead first
followed by the the corporate world and
here we we have an organization a
commercial organization that's actually
ahead of pretty much everyone else in
the development and applicability of
exosomes
so in 2008 Dr Scott founded uh the
company that I work for exosome
Diagnostics and then we went on from
there in 2012
the National Institute of Health
instituted common fund Initiative for
exosome research and the field has
exploded uh there are thousands of
exosome papers that are published yearly
so what do we know about exosomes
well we know that they're released by
pretty much all normal and cancerous
cells they're small vesicles a double
bilayer vesicles and they contain a
representation of the cells that shed
them which means they contain RNA DNA
and protein and we now know as you'll
see in a second that the reform of cell
to cell communication
and actually they are very stable for
RNA which is a very labile uh part of
the cell
exosomes protect RNA very well and that
has worked to the advantage for clinical
Diagnostics
so exosomes because they provide such
protection from the elements for their
contents and in our particular use we're
specific we're primarily talking about
RNA they're an excellent source for
biomarker use
it can actually be used for RNA
transcriptome profiling and exosomes are
completely separate and apart from what
you may know about circulating tumor DNA
or ctcs
these small vesicles as I mentioned are
produced by all cells and that includes
eukaryotes prokaryotes and we know now
through the thousands of papers produced
every year that they play a variety of
roles in normal physiology as well as
different disease States in fact they're
even being used for drug delivery
let's talk a little bit more about how
they're different from traditional
cellular communication
you know we're all taught about in
college about the different ways that
cells communicate everyone is familiar
with the basic Pathways of endocrine
paracrine neuronal and contact
versions of cell to cell communication
this is what is in basic textbooks and
what I used to be able to say were that
exosomes will be in future textbooks and
Next Generation textbooks for how we
teach science students about a new
previously unknown method of self-sell
communication I can't say that anymore
because I've actually presented this
through recent medical residents who've
actually learned about this in medical
textbooks so exosome mediated self-sell
communication is now actually being
taught as a new method of cell
communication in textbooks that we use
in medical school
so exosomes are actual mediators of
various biological processes and I've
talked about that in a general way now
let me talk about it in a specific way
I'm going to place these all up on the
screen at the same time they're known to
be involved in everything from memory
and learning to cancer suppression
they're involved in virus cloaking in
other words it's been demonstrated that
uh as a number of viruses can actually
be packaged into an exosome and
therefore evade uh UV inactivation which
is a great concern obviously for
processes that use that methodology to
try to provide a virus free or uh
environment they're involved in various
parasitical infections I'm showing you
schistosomes which are worms that reside
in the blood system for up to 30 years
as well as ticks they're now known to
carry Flava viruses when ticks bite
humans they modify the tumor
microenvironment and then of course the
one I say for last is the space the
astronaut because we're actually doing
research and published with NASA we have
a long ongoing relationship with NASA
looking at physiologic changes in
astronauts spending long periods of time
aboard the International Space Station
using exosomes to do the actual research
so exosomes when you look at the
literature are involved in pretty much
any biologic process that you can
imagine and there being more and more is
being learned about them literally every
day
so what we're doing now at the moment is
understanding the bear tip of the
iceberg
let me talk about some of the clinical
and research applications as being done
that we're doing
well once you release exosomes the first
thing to know is that exosomes are found
in every fluid every normal bodily fluid
whether it's saliva semen urine blood
plasma
exosomes was created into all of these
fluid secretions and that makes them
exceptionally useful for liquid-based
biopsy approaches so once you have a
biofluid the key to being successful for
using exosomes for clinical applications
is being able to customize isolation
method that is based on the fluid that
you're using and the application that
you want to use the exosomes for But
ultimately once you're successfully
isolating exosomes for particular
research utility
uh our goal is to be able to do
biomarker pathway analysis of what's
going on in the body in both normal
physiologic as well as cancer processes
in fact uh a lot of the work that we're
doing uh in-house is ranging from
mutation analysis and various splice
fusions to methylation full
transcriptome analysis we can do full
transcriptome analysis on exosomes
collected in small amount of urine it's
not even blood but it's urine so it's a
non-invasive way of collecting
biological samples we can do protein and
fat analysis it's an amazing amount of
data that Rivals what you can get from
tissue analysis but do it in either an
invasive or a non-invasive way depending
on the fluid that you select and in
particular exosomes have a lot of power
for Diagnostics actual clinical
Diagnostics and that's because they can
be used in a multiple uh different types
of ways they can be used early in the
disease process to try to detect which
patients are succumbing to a disease
earlier than might be seen with a
traditional tissue-based biopsy they can
be used for longitudinal tracking during
the course of a disease they provide
real-time biologic snapshots of what's
going on in the patient's biology and
the potential response to treatments as
we're treating the patient
as I mentioned earlier with urine they
can be minimally or non-invasive at all
because they're these exosomes are
present in pretty much every bodily
fluid
and they overcome tissue heterogeneity
concerns in uh cancer one of the things
that we're concerned about is the
difference between tumors and within
tumors they overcome that because we're
collecting exosomes that are secreted by
a range of the tumors that are present
and in prostate cancer which I'm going
to talk about in just a second
tumor heterogeneity is a very big
concern and then finally exosomes have a
real big advantage over traditional
methods of looking at in biofluids such
as circulating tumor cells or cell free
DNA because they provide tremendous
amplification of tissue
exosomes carry the markers of Interest
the biomarkers of interest to their
destination before they're released that
provides amplification within normal
physiology but it also allows us to
collect and have the advantage of
tremendous signal to noise as we collect
exosomes and look for biomarkers of
Interest
let's talk about the clinical challenge
in prostate cancer in prostate cancer
specifically focused on early prior to
any actual prostate cancer diagnosis
about which men can safely defer a
biopsy and what that means is when you
go in for a biopsy or when you go in for
a physical and you receive some sort of
concerning risk assessment in other
words you have an elevated PSA or you
have a digital rectal exam where the
doctor tries to feel if there's anything
abnormal going on in the prostate
those patients then have to with their
Physicians make decisions on having a
prostate biopsy and it's not a
straightforward decision because most of
those men do not need a biopsy the ones
that do often don't receive one so how
do you determine which patients really
need a biopsy and should have one and
which can safely wait to have one
specifically we're going to talk about
where that works
within the actual process which is
building on the screen right now
typically patients when they visit their
Primary Physicians
will have their annual physicals and
then based as I mentioned a second ago
about whether they have elevated PSA or
a positive digital record exam called
the GRE they'll be asked to go see their
urologist the urologists will repeat the
PSA and the digital rectal exam and then
discuss with the patient based on the
findings whether they should go for a
biopsy which is typically in the United
States around the 12 needle core biopsy
which
not every patient as I mentioned need
but based on that
biopsy the tissue is then fixed and sent
to a pathologist based on that the
Pathologists will look and see if they
find any prostate cancer assign a risk
level for that prostate cancer because
there's both low risk prostate cancer
which currently is just being watched by
doctors and there's higher grade more
concerning prostate cancer and those
patients are typically sent for
treatment and if a patient doesn't find
anything on their initial biopsy they
often go back at a subsequent point in
the future for another biopsy called the
repeat biopsy sometimes they go back for
more than one so this biopsy decision is
important
because within the elevated PSA there's
an area known as The Gray Zone which is
2 to 10 nanograms per ml once again two
to ten we're talking about a billionth
of a gram per ml two to ten billionths
of a gram per ML and the reason it's so
confusing in this area to know which
patients truly might have a concerning
prostate cancer or any prostate cancer
is because there are other reasons
non-specific reasons that can cause PSA
to be elevated less than 10 10 nanograms
per ml part of that has to do with
physical activity and part of that has
to do with other conditions such as
benign prostatic hyperplasia which can
also cause elevated PSA so how do you
determine which patients go forward and
why is that important what's important
because you don't want to unnecessarily
expose people to prostate biopsies if
you don't have to but at the same time
you want to
see the right patients up to go on the
left hand side of the scale you can see
the various
complications associated with biopsy
that range from pain which is expected
to unfortunately infections which really
about one to four percent based on the
literature of patients have infections
that are concerning and sending them to
the hospital and you need to remember
that these patients are prophylactically
treated with antibiotics and so there is
always a concern about
antibiotic resistant bacterial
infections here but at the same time on
the other side of the scale we know that
since PSA guidelines changed in 2013
without going into the details we do see
an increase in the rise of distant
metastasis and prostate cancer and
therefore we want to send the right
people for biopsy and not everyone and
we want to be able to defer for the
right people as well so how do you do
that well that's where we start to talk
about how exosomes can be used and are
being used in a clinical asset
so there's a lot of data but in the
interest of time I want to show you just
one study from the Journal of the
American Medical Association that covers
one specific assay there is only one
assay that's being currently clinically
used in clinical Diagnostics it's this
particular assay it was this study was
done in a large perspective blinded
clinical trial for men 50 years or older
with PSA in that Gray Zone of 2 to 10
nanograms per ML and this particular
assay is able to discriminate which
patients are likely to find high-grade
cancer defined as a Gleason score of 7
or higher
from low-grade disease which is a
Gleason score of six and benign tissue
and this particular test if you look at
the bar chart shows and this is what
you're looking at is area under the
curve which is how most diagnostic
assays prognostic assays are measures
balance of sensitivity and specificity
and it's a probability scale if you look
at this you can see that PSA has which
is traditionally the biomarker of choice
PSA has an area under the curve of 0.55
which is the equivalent of tossing a
coin
when you add clinical features in into
the PCP TRC which is a prostate cancer
calculator an algorithm that combines
clinical features in PSA you can see
that it goes it does better
standard of care was an in-house
standard of care calculator combining
clinical features and PSA it's
essentially the same as the published
calculators and when you get to the
exosome based test which is the Epi
bar column you'll see the significant
increase in area under the Curve
and finally when you add standard of
care features which on their own are
quite poor to the exosome based assay
there's very little movement in
performance as measured by area under
the curve and therefore what that shows
is that the biomarker itself is
collecting pretty much all of the
diagnostic information that's available
and stands on its own and as a result of
this and other studies this particular
assay was launched into the marketplace
the health prostate cancer or patients
going through an early detection for
prostate cancer process and is used in
in the field quite widely
in fact subsequent data showed that if
you look at the top chart that in this
homogeneous group of patients 2 to 10
nanograms per ml there was an
association an increase in the scores of
this exosome based biomarker assay as
you go from the left to the right you
see that the scores go up and the scores
go up in association with the detection
of high-grade prostate cancer
so in other words the higher the score
the higher the likelihood up until about
a Max of 50 60 percent of finding high
grade cancer and there is a maximum
there because prostate cancer biopsy by
itself although it is the gold standard
actually does Miss about 50 percent of
cancers
if you look at the chart on the bottom
what you would find is that PSA within
the 2 to 10 nanogram per ml range
regardless of how you bucket it out
actually doesn't
have any ability to discriminate which
patients have any cancer let alone
prostate cancer
so how do you use this clinically
well there's right now for early
detection there's a discussion about how
biomarkers and multi-parametric MRI can
be put together to provide benefit to
patients in fact it was fairly recent
editorial here in 20 at the end of 2022
that actually talks about potential
scenarios for putting biomarkers and MRI
together
and the short answer is is that we're in
the infancy of how we do this nobody
understands completely what particular
process is best but we do know that
biomarkers and MRI both have their own
strengths and limitations and when you
look at MRI which is accepted uh widely
in guidelines for clinical use for early
detection what you would find is that it
is a risk assessment method similar to
biomarkers that provides a probability
of finding concerning tumors this
particular chart shows in red the
percentage of high grade tumors in a
risk assessment method known as pirate
scoring and prostate cancer so these
grades three through five are considered
from intermediate to high risk cancer by
multi-parametric MRI and what you find
is at the low end there's only a small
percentage of high grade prostate cancer
that increases but is still not a
hundred percent even when you get to the
highest grade and so from a risk
assessment point of view MRI has its own
strengths and weaknesses for teeing up
patients for early detection for high
grade prostate cancer so how do you
combine biomarkers with
multi-parametric MRI to provide a
benefit and we're in the process uh as
as a community of doing that right now
one of the papers I want to show you in
the uh interests of time that's looked
at this
is this paper out of UCSF so let me skip
that and this paper I by de la Caye at
Al explored how to potentially combine
MRI and biomarkers together it is an
observational study it is not a
prospective trial which is needed but
what they did was they looked at some of
the commercially available
biomarkers and then suggests the
potential ways that they might work
together and in this study everyone had
a biopsy they had no previous prostate
cancer diagnosis none of these people
were diagnosed with prostate cancer
their PSAs were all below 20 nanograms
per ML and they must have had one of the
commercial biomarker results and if I
were to skip the chase
I would show you this result this is the
exosome based assay that I've been
mentioning
and in purple what you're seeing is the
number of MRI excuse me of biopsies that
could be avoided
and the missed percentage of prostate
cancer that you would find and what they
found ultimately is this particular
algorithm called algorithm IV and in
this algorithm they put the exosome
based biomarker first and then based on
the results of the exosome based results
decided whether those patients went for
biopsy and MRI and what they found was
that they were able to avoid 43 percent
of biopsies that they didn't believe
were necessary and only miss less than
five percent of Gleason seven or higher
high grade disease
and they were able to avoid almost 40
percent of MRIs now although this is an
observational trial and it doesn't have
the power of a prospective trial studies
like this are indicating that MRI and
biomarkers and in this particular case
an exosome based biomarker can be used
together to provide better patient care
and this study concluded the way that I
think that we need to discuss it which
is that prospective validation studies
are being developed and are needed to
actually determine the best way to put
biomarkers and MRI together to help
patients in prostate cancer but I would
argue in in multiple types of cancer but
in prostate cancer where I focus that's
where we're going
so I hope that what you've come away
with from this presentation is the fact
that you understand how what exosomes
are at least a high level and if you
didn't know about them you're interested
in learning more about them that these
exosomes are not only have been
developed uh for use in the clinic but
actually there is one clinical assay in
the world that I'm aware of that is
currently being used in the field of
early detection for prostate cancer and
in that specific clinical Niche it's
addressing PSA issues and earlier
requests from the field and from various
agencies for biomarkers that improve the
specificity of detection and it AIDS
patients and their Physicians for making
shared decisions that improve patient
compliance and quality of care and
unfortunately due to time considerations
I don't have time to go over the level
one study that actually reviews some of
that
and then finally key that this exosomes
can on their own without any inclusion
of clinical features provide an
independent perspective on risk
assessment in this particular case for
prostate cancer and then ultimately for
other uh disease States as well thank
you for attending and if you have any
questions please put them in the Q a box
and I will answer them directly when
they're provided to me I appreciate your
time in listening to this and I hope it
was useful